[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bill
freudenheim and um
the title of will's thesis is the
network and the classroom a history of
hypermedia learning environments
and i'm going to hand it over to eric
to introduce thanks vivek um uh before
before i introduce will i just want to
say how excellent all the work has been
but also
to note how diverse it's been um and yet
um the
the whole student of this whole student
community has been
clearly supportive of each other and i
just want to give a call out to the
whole student community for for their
work
um through challenging times here so
thank you to all of you for that
um so now i'll introduce will um
uh so i first met will a couple years
ago at pax east
um uh he had applied to the program i
think he had gotten into the program
and i met him at pax east to see some of
his work that he was working on in games
um and was thrilled that when he was
announced he was coming to the program
because he had done such great work
there came here started working i'm
actually i'm wearing the playful journey
lab
official uh garment here where he's been
working uh
at mit and started doing work on games
and continued to work on some of the
work on games and
assessment there but um found his thesis
passion and interest around
hypermedia um and uh and i've been
uh i've learned a lot um through his
journey through hypermedia
i've been looking at his relationship to
education and learning
and noted uh that um
uh he takes i don't want to give too
much away but he's give sort of a
historical perspective on hyper media
um and that history um sort of coincides
with my lifetime so
i've kind of lived along a lot of the
thesis work that he'll be talking about
today so
um with that i will let will take it
away
thank you so much eric um let me just
share my screen here
um okay you may be uh blessed
today a little bit with some new york
city traffic noises throughout my
presentation
um okay so i'm gonna begin can everybody
see this
is this visible okay great um so i'm
gonna begin with some of the personal uh
kind of origins of this topic for me
um i was one of those students growing
up who immediately upon
graduating high school felt like i had
kind of already forgotten a significant
portion of what i had learned throughout
my years of education
and as i began college for the first
time i had the opportunity to choose
classes not only that i was excited
about
but that overlapped with each other in
different ways that felt meaningful to
try to document
build upon and return to throughout this
time i felt the kind of like lingering
anxiety that i would come away from
these years
of school feeling like i had when i
finished high school that
i had all these deeply meaningful
discussions and lectures and readings
which would soon kind of drift out of
memory
so what i realized i was looking for was
a system for organizing my own knowledge
that could act like a thinking partner
not just an ever-growing pile of
notebooks and readings but a system for
organizing ideas that could let thoughts
intermingle that could accompany my
learning
and that would be valuable and
generative to return to and explore
and ideally a tool that i could use in
collaboration with others to share ideas
as we learned
so in the past five years there have
been actually an explosion
in popularity of these types of tools
for creating network systems for
organizing and sharing knowledge and
while this type of tool isn't always
described using one single term
i refer to this genre of tool as hyper
media knowledge organization tools and
i'll take a moment to kind of break that
down
so at its most simple hypermedia the
term hypermedia comes from
hypertext which refers to text which is
not constrained to be linear and where
the text itself
contains linkages to other text or other
documents which a user can kind of
follow based on their own interest
and then from there comes hyper media
more broadly
which refers to systems where other
media forms like images and video can be
connected
in similar ways the most obvious example
of hypertext and hypermedia
is the internet itself where you follow
hyperlinks to navigate networks of pages
and content
and then when i say knowledge
organization tools
i'm referring quite broadly to tools and
practices which help arrange
and document ideas and concepts
so taken together hypermedia knowledge
organization tools refers to
tools which allow users to document
organize and develop ideas
which employ these practices of linking
and network forming
to to form these like networks of
interconnected thoughts
so many of these recent tools
promise to positively affect how people
think learn and generate ideas
these new tools make claims for helping
people create a second brain in this
example here by creating and following
connections between notes and ideas
they emphasize nonlinear note taking and
knowledge organizing and
typically employ imagery as well as user
interfaces that incorporate these
interconnected nodes of ideas um which
you can see here this is a tool called
rom research
furthermore they emphasize uh
collaboration and connection making
across contexts
is another tool called arena where you
can locate single ideas in multiple
folders at once
and then finally many of these tools
propose that thinking and learning
happen in these shared organizing spaces
so while these recent tools make pretty
lofty claims about their
new features to help create context for
improved thinking and learning
they build upon both technology and
pedagogy that has been developing since
the early days of personal computers
despite this history and its links to
these tools and
and to learning itself we see little
transformation of the classroom as
connected to these types of tools today
why is this and can or should we seek to
change that
um so in this thesis i ask how can
classrooms use
emerging systems for collaboratively
sharing and organizing knowledge in
order to benefit learners
and how can we learn from the past in
order to better shape the future of this
work
i argue that examining the history of
hypermedia oriented learning tools by
looking at both
successful and failed experiments and
bringing them to classrooms
one can more deeply understand both the
conceptual origins of these recent
networked knowledge tools
and consider where they might be able to
fit into today's classrooms as well as
how to avoid challenges that have
plagued them in the past
um so indeed there's a whole lineage of
these types of interactive and
collaborative tools
for organizing knowledge as networks
that have been experimented with in
classrooms
since the 1980s in this thesis i look at
two
previous moments of intense development
in this space
one in the mid-1980s and another in the
mid-2000s before then turning to examine
these tools in the present moment
at each of these points i look at
technological shifts as well as trends
in the learning sciences which together
inform
both the design and application of these
tools
in doing so i examine and draw lessons
from the frictions involved in using
these tools in educational contexts
in order to consider and propose ways in
which these new tools might be
able to be used to support learning in
classrooms today
as i do so i look at emulations and
technical documentation of older
software
i look at advertisements promotional
material and video content of people
using these tools um and then i survey a
pretty wide variety of research studies
describing the application of hypermedia
learning tools in
in learning contexts uh from each of
these points
so in in this presentation today i'm
going to do kind of two things
first is give a sort of a quick
historical overview of the development
of these tools and the connections
between hypermedia and learning as
they've developed
and discuss some of the frictions
between educational media
hypermedia and classrooms along the way
and then i'll shift gears and describe
the current generation of these tools
and point to three approaches
that these types of tools could be used
in classrooms
one of which i implemented in a middle
school classroom context in the fall
but before getting there i want to touch
on why why this area is important
firstly building new capacities to
document organize and structure
knowledge is a crucial 21st century
skill
and one that becomes ever more relevant
when encountering increasing information
information saturation that we all deal
with today
however um making changes to education
broadly
is an incredibly challenging task and
particularly in the context of
educational technology
new tools with great promise come in and
out of popularity quite regularly
and very rarely make any significant
changes in popular educational discourse
in his book uh failure to disrupt why
technology alone can't transform
education
justin reich talks in depth about why so
many of the technologies which have been
promised will radically transform
educational practices have failed
he sets forth a juxtaposition between
two stances the
charismatic stance and the tinkering
stance the charismatic stance typically
accompanies technological innovation
it's the notion that technology itself
inherently will offer wholesale
transformation of existing systems and
it's this stance that often
fails in comparison the tinkering stance
he says
sees schools and universities as complex
systems which can be improved
but they believe that major improvement
is the product of many years of
incremental changes to existing
institutions rather than the result of
one stroke of wholesale renewal
so with this thesis i hope to take a
tinkerer's stance on considering
the possible value of these types of
tools i see this in trying to pull
lessons from the earlier eras of
hypermedia learning that i examine
and consider how these uh how these
tools might be able to offer some
incremental changes to
classrooms um
so first i'm going to talk a little bit
about some of the origins of the
connection between
hypermedia and and learning so
any account of the history of hypertext
and hypermedia tends to begin with uh
van over bush
um he was an american engineer and
inventor um and led the us office of
scientific research and development
throughout world war ii
following the war bush sought to imagine
uh schools
um sorry imagine tools which might be
able to
enable the human mind to more readily
think and learn across disciplines
in part this stemmed from a fear that
the increasing hyper-specialization
which he saw amongst his research
organizations would lead to a mountain
of inaccessible knowledge
it is 1945 piece in the atlantic titled
as we may think
bush proposed a device called the memex
to deal with this challenge
the memex was a device which would hold
microfilm copies of a user's personal
library
and allow them to make automatic
connections between text such that they
could
create chains of intertextual
association users of the memex device
would save and share these paths of
ideas between texts as well as their
notes about them
as is apparent in the title of this
piece bush wanted to develop a device
that he operates as he believed
we may think this notion that the mind
naturally operates by association
carries throughout this entire text as
he says
with one item in its grasp the brain
instantly snaps to the next
that is suggested by the association of
thoughts in accordance with some
intricate web of trails carried by the
cells of the brain
so embedded in his writing are few
notions about learning that carry across
many of the hypermedia tools for
organizing knowledge that developed in
the following years
first is the idea that the mind
naturally thinks and learns by making
these associations
the second is that associations between
ideas can link together
from one to the next to form trails of
connection as bush describes
developing tools by which one can create
and save these trails will allow for
deeper learning
and then third is that these trails are
meaningful chunks of knowledge which can
be built collaboratively
where sharing and co-creating networks
of association between ideas
will inherently lead to deeper learning
and then uh in in the 20 in the 20 years
that followed
the the terms hypertext and hypermedia
themselves were later coined by ted
nelson
um in the 1960s who imagined digital
systems which would use these models
he created diagrams to illustrate the
idea of hypertext and hypermedia one of
which
you can see here and and this this
imagery is often repeated uh throughout
the types of tools uh that we look at
today
so um okay yes
um though this optimism in the power of
hypermedia to accelerate learning
remained semi-dormant for a few decades
in terms of tools that were actually
developed
by the mid-1980s multiple hypermedia
platforms simultaneously sprung forth
that were specifically designed for the
educational context
researchers from across educational and
commercial institutions
promised that hypermedia oriented
learning tools would offer learners
newer and faster ways of accessing
knowledge new modes of collaboration
and new types of interaction to enable
learners to forge connections between
ideas
by the mid-20th century new theories of
knowledge acquisition began to describe
learning and thinking
as processes using computational and
diagrammatic metaphors which sounded
much like
ted nelson and fanbar bush's early
descriptions of hypertext systems
these perspectives on learning were
foundational in bridging the language of
hypertext to the language of learning
which deeply informed the educational
hypermedia tools to come
so i'm going to talk about two of them
briefly
one model of learning that stands out
for its overlap with hypertext
vocabulary
is the model of schemas a concept from
psychology and cognitive science which
describes patterns of thought or
behavior which organize information and
the relationships between them
the model of schema considers mental
constructs as
individual nodes which together form
networks of ideas through associative
structures which consist of attributes
and
relationships between them schemas focus
attention on the role that
old knowledge plays and inquire in
acquiring new knowledge in the sense
that
new knowledge is filtered and
interpreted through these webs of
pre-existing associations
another important model to understand
learning that was growing in popularity
at this time
was the idea of social constructivism in
the educational context social
constructivism emphasizes the deeply
collaborative nature of learning
suggesting that knowledge develops
through how people interact with each
other
their culture and society at large in
classroom learning
students rely on others to help create
their own building blocks with which
they incorporate new ideas and interpret
their existing assumptions about reality
so thinking about the computer as an
educational tool in the context of
schemas and social constructivism it
became clear that computers could be
used as tools to think
with hypertext-based tools could readily
act as a digital environment through
which
learners could model and extend the
social construction of knowledge
by creating open and unstructured
databases that allow for collaboration
learners can add and connect ideas and
support and challenge each other's
perspectives
so at the same time as all this was
happening new developments in computing
were simultaneously
essential in creating the conditions for
these these new
educational hypertext experiences to
develop so
um just to give a kind of overview of
the like early 80s moment
in 1981 ibm was releasing its first
personal computer
which which was the first to gain
massive industry adoption um
france telecom offered the mintel
terminals which became the largest
online service before the world wide web
uh in 82 lan operating systems emerged
which allowed
uh network links between computers and
offices in 83 microsoft
introduced 84 the cd-rom explode in
popularity
um so by 1985 essentially computers
uh commercial computers had become
powerful enough to store and manipulate
multiple just as networking practices
were becoming increasingly possible
the business sector um both of which are
crucial in developing the types of uh
interactive platforms that will come
so i'm going to talk about one of the um
hyper media knowledge organization tools
that was developed during this time
called intermedia
so intermediate was a hypermedia tool
developed at brown university
um between 1985 and 1991
the tool the project was accompanied by
by a team of
both computer scientists and
ethnographers who produced research
papers about how it was received as what
collected documentary footage
at the outset of this project the team
describes intermediate as a vision to
create
a vast multimedia information
environment where no piece of
information is ever isolated and where
every word
picture and idea can be linked to any
other intermedia was not so much one
tool as it was a suite of applications
which explains its kind of plural name
you can get a sense of this from the
screenshot here where you can see on the
left
a web that was created which links out
to multiple documents on 19th century
health records
and each of the documents themselves
linked to each other
and then over on the right you can see a
kind of like history of all the
different kinds of edits and linkages
that people were creating and building
so in the ethnographic report students
referred to
working with intermediate as going to
intermedia because all the intermediate
terminals were housed in one room
so to them this experience of
intermediate was not
as much the software as it was the
content held in the software as it was
the
physical space that housed it it was
this kind of total experience
the the first intermediate pilot with
two uh was with
two classes at brown an english survey
course in a biology course
the two courses were selected as a proof
of concept of the flexibility of the
system
if the same tool could be used to
enhance learning in the distinct
cultures of the sciences and the
humanities
then surely it would be useful to a
broader selection of courses
the professors for the each course and
the research team together
built an entire corpus of reference
materials for the work before the
before the courses began inputting and
linking hundreds of documents together
students could contribute their own
content to their to the intermediate
environment by
adding their own writing by linking
elements uh from their own or others
work together
or inputting other resource materials
while students and educators often
head of a range of experiences using
intermediate over the course of the
entire semester
the learning outcomes of engaging with
this tool were considered largely quite
successful
both in terms of students performance on
exams for the biology course
as well as the kind of depth of
connection making and discussion
for the students in the english course
so this is one example of the types of
experiments that was occurring during
this time
in the thesis i talk about two other
significant hypermedia knowledge
organization tools from this era
one is called cecil which later turned
into a tool called knowledge forum
and another called hypercard which was
not explicitly
educational but was used quite a bit in
educational contexts
however looking across the research
studies uh from from
throughout these three tools um and
about the various ways that they were
used in classrooms
at this time a few kind of patterns of
frictions become clear
so many of these early experiments
required so much pre-set up
like intermediate where a professors and
a team of workers entered a huge amount
of material before the course began
um while some of these early experiments
were themselves successful and learners
had positive experiences
they were typically quite unrealistic to
imagine setting up at any larger scale
furthermore there was quite a
significant number of technical
challenges with using these tools as
well
so operating networked computer labs at
that point
was expensive and not not yet a norm um
loading and interacting with network
systems could at times be incredibly
slow and cumbersome
and this was particularly a big problem
for intermedia
and then for many just becoming familiar
with interacting with the computer was
was a new experience and required
significant onboarding time
um so that's like a little picture of
this mid-1980s moment
shifting forward now i'll describe kind
of a moment
a bit of the time in between and then
we'll jump to the 2000s so
despite the the failure of the tools
from the 1980s and early 90s to gain
widespread traction
in classrooms by the mid 1990s
it was becoming increasingly clear that
the world was rapidly changing alongside
developments
and mass popularizations of computers
and the early internet
in popular educational discourse there
were a plurality of descriptions of what
this future computer-enabled world would
look like and notions of how to adapt
educational practices in order to better
prepare learners for this new landscape
by 2005 the broad shift toward a more
highly interactive internet
only further fueled excitement about
participatory web-based learning tools
this broad shift in how websites were
designed was described as web 2.0
a term uh used for new websites that
were structured to enable user generated
and participatory content interactions
with
things like the growth of social media
blogs and video sharing sites
at the same time a broad and
interdisciplinary pedagogical approach
called computer-supported collaborative
learning or cscl
was beginning to gain significantly more
traction
in cscl approaches which build upon a
combination of
educational psychology instructional
technology and social psychology
learning occurs through social
interactions using shared digital spaces
where
learners collaboratively construct
knowledge using technology as their
primary means of communication or as a
shared resource
though the cscl community had existed
for a few decades
the availability of more collaborative
platforms on the internet led to a
significant expansion
in the cscl community and its research
many educational researchers across cl
and other disciplines
took this collaborative potential and
growing popularity of the internet and
imagined how these tools could be used
in concert with the broadly
constructivist learning strategies to
enable learners to more effectively
participate in a networked society
so of these new web 2.0 platforms that
were rapidly growing in popularity
the wiki became a format onto which
researchers began to imagine new
possibilities for developing
collaborative learning experiences in
the classroom
so while everyone is likely familiar
with wikipedia
which is the most widely known wiki
wikis generally
are wikis more broadly are a kind of
general form of hypertext publication
that is collaboratively edited and
managed directly inside of the web
browser
wikis themselves run on wiki engines
many of which are freely open source and
could be readily tinkered with by
researchers and educators
so while in the kind of first section of
my thesis i looked at kind of a spread
of different tools and how they were
used in classrooms
in this chapter i typically i focus on
wikis as a kind of general model
which were and continue to be used in a
wide variety of different learning
contexts
so there are a few uh there are a number
of aspects of how wikis are designed
that are particularly
appeal to this kind of constructivist
approach
like earlier hypermedia models wikis
allow users to organize and present
content in a way that does not prescribe
a set organizational form at the outset
and can allow for kind of organic growth
wikis use pages as nodes which can refer
to each other to form a network which
does not need to be predetermined
this offers the potential for students
to build out wikis as they follow
self-directed learning
adding or linking new pages as they
potentially follow their own interests
so beginning around 2005 educators and
researchers
proposed and developed a wide variety of
learning experiences which brought wikis
into the classroom
across a variety of different maturities
of learners across different subject
areas and across context
so i'll talk about a few sort of like
general models of wikis that
were used in education um
the first is a resource wiki um
so resource wikis are collaborative
knowledge bases where learners
contribute to their contribute their
knowledge to an
expanding encyclopedic resource
resource wikis are typically more
outward facing meaning that they are
less intended to contain in progress
documentation of learning processes
and instead are able to function as a
knowledge base that could be legible and
potentially useful
to external readers beyond the class
itself
students might be assigned to creating
specific article style entries
uh integrating text and images and
attribution to cited articles
these types of wikis are intended to
perform like wikipedia
as a resource containing reliably
sourced information
one one related genre of wiki usage
involves presentation wikis
which are a way of using wikis to create
and document in progress learning
and knowledge in a format that is less
concerned with being presentable to an
outsider
and more focused on being useful for
learners
presentation wikis have more room for
individuals to use their own writing
styles and tones
and while while learners using
presentation wikis will link their pages
and ideas together
it's more likely to be intentionally
apparent who developed each page on the
wiki
in order to assess the contributors as
well
presentation wikis are more likely to
have segmented areas where
contributors are working individually or
collaboratively in private spaces
where more finished work will kind of be
added to the publicly accessible zone
upon completion and then one one third
example of using wikis that i'll mention
just briefly
is using them for co-writing as an
opportunity to bring students away from
the kind of traditional solitary mode of
written work and toward
collective writing processes which offer
not only opportunities for
to practice reading and writing but
involve critical thinking reflection
and uh like regular interaction
so reflecting on the years of research
using
wikis in classrooms there are a number
of different kinds of challenges
in using them that stand out from from
the challenges of the
that the tools in the mid 80s dealt with
one one significant one was that
evaluating both performance and
individuals contributions
in this context is very difficult um for
for shared and collaborative spaces
um these evaluations became increasingly
crucial during
um the the 2005 forward era
of heightened standardized testing and
no child left behind
secondly um more meta research from 2009
and so onward
indicated that in many cases learners
didn't actually display deeply
collaborative behaviors using them
so this was often the case where when
students like procrastinate
they vastly reduce the possibility for
collaboration um
like when working against a time crunch
students are like less likely to take
the time to reflect on each other's work
or thoughtfully cross-reference between
wiki pages and are much more likely to
focus on just finishing their own
content
furthermore working with limited time
learners don't typically
can't typically give in-progress
feedback to their peers
furthermore wikis themselves typically
by default are are much more stripped
down than than some of the earlier tools
even than the ones described in the 80s
in the sense that they don't have uh
built-in modes of visualizing
uh networks of ideas and and where
content or or
individual nodes can only live in one
place rather than a plurality of them
uh at once and then one final one final
friction in classrooms was that
discussion areas on wikis are typically
separated out from the content areas and
so
having deeper discussions it was
challenging to point to specific
uh specific notes in the wiki
all right so now i'm going to shift
gears a little bit and talks about
some of the contemporary hypermedia
tools for knowledge organization
some of the features of them and then
describe uh kind of three applications
that i see them being used
in today's classrooms so as i mentioned
at the at the opening of this
presentation there have been a variety
of new types of tools which draw upon
this non-linear network-oriented model
of documenting and organizing knowledge
um the design of this recent generation
of tools combines many of the important
uh design aspects from each of the
previous
points that i examined earlier so like
the mid-2000s
kind of wiki moment these recent
hypermedia knowledge organization tools
are
are are accessible and primarily
browser-based
they are synchronously editable meaning
that users can actually see
each other's changes in real time but
these tools also borrow a lot of the
design decisions from the 80s as well
many of which emphasize the importance
of multi-contextuality where
one idea can simultaneously link out to
multiple places at once rather than
kind of one directional link they
prioritize creating and connecting
smaller nodes of information
so while with the wiki where the page
was kind of the individual node that
could connect to other pages
many of these contemporary tools
prioritize creating and connecting
smaller chunks of information together
like individual bullet points or
individual images
um and then finally many of these
emerging platforms offer multiple ways
of creating and viewing the connections
between information and their
relationships as well
so often employing graph views to kind
of visualize nodes of interconnection
so the the final section of my thesis
then asks
where might uh these ideas and platforms
fit into classrooms today
and how can we learn from some of these
frictions of previous tools
so i identify three possible ways that i
see these contemporary tools being used
that avoid some of the aforementioned
frictions
and the each of these models are just
inspired uh by practices that i've
seen people using online the first
is the concept of creating a digital
garden so
digital gardens are online spaces that
look something like
a combination of a notebook and a blog
digital gardeners write essays or short
form pieces
and use backlinks at the end of each
page to point to other pieces inside
their garden
to connect the piece the reader is
currently reading
to others it's like a kind of personal
website or a blog with the added notion
that
the written pieces are intentionally
interlinked together
and in addition this kind of garden
metaphor implies that the connections on
each page
as well as the content itself will be
tended to
and that the posts themselves aren't
meant to be final but can grow later on
digital gardens are a model that could
be useful in a variety of contexts
but for an example a middle school-aged
learner in an english class could use a
digital garden to write
not only their homework assignments
essays and creative work
in one shared space and could be
encouraged to explicitly
make connections between these different
forms
this model is developed by an individual
rather than a group and is more focused
on
organizing and sharing work that a
learner has themselves created rather
than
inputting knowledge created by others so
this has the benefit of giving teachers
a space with which to evaluate the
student's work as they use the tool
a second approach is using these shared
knowledge organization tools for
creating collaborative research
repositories
so using these tools learners that are
part of a class or group of classes
can collectively gather organize and
annotate external materials that will be
useful for
research and writing that will be
developed separately
this is a type of practice that i've
seen on one of the tools called arena
that i examined previously this type of
model will allow students to
help each other gather materials that
will be useful for their own individual
work
and in doing so builds a shared system
that is potentially useful
to the entire class as a whole and while
this model is inherently collaborative
it's in a kind of pre-writing context
that avoids the challenges of
needing to figure out how to grade
individual students on their
contributions
um and then the third model that i talk
about
which is what i explore in a little bit
more depth in in a case study
is using networked tools to support uh
social emotional learning in classrooms
um this model is inspired by a project
that i worked on with the playful
journey lab at mit
in collaboration with a 7th grade
massachusetts area public
middle school classroom in the fall we
used
a tool called realm research which is
one of the contemporary tools that i
go over in the thesis to host an
activity series format that focused on
collaborative reflection
in order to support uh students and
teachers to acknowledge
a kind of wide variety of experiences
and types of learning that that happened
throughout the pandemic
um the types of prompts that we designed
uh involved
uh virtual making and collaborative
writing um
that that that also incorporated like
drawing
simple video making and taking pictures
the intention was that students
would come away from this activity
series with this
co-created collection of shared
artifacts that captured this moment in
their lives
that led to like deeper discussion and
that helped expand their ideas of what
learning is
um and in doing so they worked in this
kind of shared
uh knowledge environment um over the
course of of a semester
um using using the two these tools in
this context
is um again kind of outside of a context
that requires grading
and also further further encourages
collaboration and connection forming
um and then also using using these uh
tools for a shared social emotional
space
uh could be a way to um help learners in
in distance learning environments
as well um also also developing an
activity series
in this using this format um is a way of
avoiding some of the procrastination
problems that uh
wikipedia or the sorry that wiki's uh
often dealt with
i could talk a lot more about this
specific project um but i'm gonna kind
of
start to start to wrap up uh so
looking at both the the history and
present moment of network tools in the
context of learning
my hope today is to kind of leave you
with a gentle optimism
about their potential while i don't see
these tools on their own as
radically or fundamentally transforming
educational practices
i see that there clearly is a design
space that can be continued to be
explored using these types of tools to
support learners in a variety of
different contexts
so i think that taking a tinkerer's
approach to looking at
the past configurations of the genre of
tool and carefully
examining the contexts within which they
can be employed
is is essential to using them to create
change
and then ultimately what what is more
impo most important is
is less the tools themselves but a
careful consideration of how they fit
into the environments in which we use
them
so thank you all so much um thank you to
eric and justin for
for all of your help as well as um
everybody here
thanks
all right i'm open for questions
eric thanks will i i enjoyed hearing
your presentation there and
and of course uh going through this this
journey with you um
my question is really is a little bit of
a little bit of a hypothetical situation
but
i i also asked in the context of this
with the the tinker and the charismatic
um so you sort of documented this case
of of
of tinkering over decades um in this in
this space of hyper media with respect
to schools
um so imagine imagine you can take one
of the tools you used to mention on the
last slide there perhaps the one that
you used
in the schools rome and um and bring it
back to a 1980s classroom
um so here you are you're the
charismatic who can
bring this this technology of the future
to the classroom
um will it sort of be more effective
than the things that they were using at
the time
um and and the context of my question is
like is it is it the process of
tinkering that's important
or is it the product of tinkering that's
important that we get to that place
through this through these years of
tinkering
yeah i think i think it has to be a
combination in the sense that i think
just
even even dropping one of these
contemporary tools even if you also
brought with it like the uh
you know the computers too uh it to that
point
uh would still i think there would still
be a lot of the same kinds of frictions
encountered i think that like
it's this process of tinkering over the
course of many years that develops a
kind of like language
around how to how to bring them into
classrooms um
and like pedagogical approaches that
that like are carefully considered over
over the course of years um that that
find their fit
at a certain point um and so i think
that
while while some of the tools at that
point were themselves quite effective um
i think that it's it's yeah the kind of
process of tinkering that it's important
yeah thanks
thank you william
will thanks that was uh terrific a
brilliant history and one i want to
learn a lot more about
can't wait to read it just to pick up on
eric's question
and the very last point you made where
you said it's more about the fit
it's less about the tools and it's more
about the fit in the context
it strikes me as just another way to
read like the the
the information you've amassed is as a
a moment in a zeitgeist the moment in in
the
the kind of technological remapping of
how consciousness works on how learning
works
if you were to jump back a century and a
half you know when photography was the
hot medium
there's a lot of emphasis being put on
like what can we learn with slides can
we learn with image how does the mind
work
there's this kind of pod to do between
the representation systems that are
being used in the classroom
and the model of how mental processes
work
like well we hold images or it's a blank
slate or it's a
photographic memory that's a discourse
that's really big in the in the
in the mid 19th century um
so what strikes me is just the kind of
the
and this goes to eric's point question i
guess like there is a kind of zeitgeist
a paradigm a notion of how consciousness
works that we
that we technologically emulate and it's
not whether the tool is good or bad it's
whether that fit
it strikes me there you it was so apt
the last thing you said it's less the
tools
and more the fit in the context i'm
using context in a different way than
you used it but i think it's still
it still kind of works um love to know
if you
any reactions to that or whatever but it
just strikes me as a brilliant
meditation on our thinking about the
learning process and
are thinking about the functioning of
consciousness through technology as the
lens
yeah that's a really interesting point i
think that i mean i was quite struck by
the fact that like this this like
associative
metaphor and this like image of these
like interconnected documents is like
persisted
now for i mean nelson kind of was
developing that that model in the 60s
and like we're
like you see these brand new tools that
are claimed that like
pretend to be entirely a historical um
that are like referencing this exact
same
diagram um so and i and i'm
it's something that i wonder like if if
perhaps it's like
through you know now however many years
of
deep engagement with the internet that
like maybe that this model is more
ready to be used than it had been
previously that like
the type maybe we're starting to see
cracks in the system and the that you
gave me three examples that you're
focusing on and one was the garden
and i'm wondering if like there's not an
ecological model that's starting to
displace
this technological computational model
um like is they say another way devil's
advocate another
idea is to say it's appealing to a new
metaphor
and it's a more organic uh more organic
one
that's really interesting yeah i mean
i've seen that's something that
i note a little bit at the end of the
thesis that i that i see
this kind of gardening metaphor actually
used quite a bit more um
in relation to these tools um that that
might even perhaps like kind of overtake
the sort of network
metaphor down the road and that's
something yeah that's something i would
love to see
happen
justin thanks will this has been
really terrific can everybody hear me
okay okay yep bad
bad connections in vermont um i wanted
to
you know a terrific history lots of
great connections and eric and william's
questions built out quite a bit
um one challenge i wanted to offer is
that it sounded
like in your final piece you were saying
something along the lines of
if we could get teachers to choose the
right kind of projects to do with rome
research
then that would um alleviate some of the
problems with previous generations
which makes me think that that's an
argument that it was the projects
in previous generations that were wrong
i wonder if you could talk about what
thoughts do you have in an alternative
view
that it's not that the projects were
wrong
nor is it the case that you could pick
the perfect rome projects and have them
fit
it's that there's a series of values in
schools
that are orthogonal to the values of
learning and participating with these
tools
right i think that yeah that's a great
point um
so yeah i think that the
that it is true that often the values of
schools absolutely are orthogonal to
effectively using these types of tools
um i guess what i'm trying to propose
is that there are still ways of using
them in
inside of the existing kind of
structures of schools that can still be
effective
um i don't know if that completely
answers your question
but well yeah i think i think you
gestured to that as well with just
something like
all right well we can't change schools
so
but there's probably like little niches
where
sufficiently devoted people will make
this work
so here are some great ways of doing
that
and i think that's good too um although
although i think
that um you know they're they're they're
you know
that which which is a which is a great
way of continuing to develop
really interesting pedagogy for the
coalition of the willing
um and uh i'm interested whether
rome or whether you know garden
metaphors or what other kinds of things
might expand that coalition to willing
interesting ways
yeah i mean i think that i think that
expanding the coalition of the willing
is i guess kind of where
where i'm sort of leaving this off i
guess um in the sense that
i definitely don't see like any mass
proliferation of the uses of these types
of
tools happening in directly inside of
classrooms like happening anytime soon
but but i think that the that finding
these
finding these kind of design language or
finding these new configurations i think
can like help expand um who who the who
the willing are what that coalition is
um and the types of uses for them
i have a somewhat tangential question
but i
as a historian and documentary and i
couldn't let this pass
you mentioned that the that the project
at brown in the late 80s
also involved documentary footage yes
can you tell me a bit more about that
was there a documentary made about it or
is it yes
there was i can actually send it yeah um
it's a great documentary because
interestingly enough there wasn't like a
ton of uh visual documentation
of the project so that so the
documentary really helped me out a lot
in
trying to understand what was happening
at that point um there was a lot of
quite a few interviews with students at
brown about their experience working
with the tool
um i didn't i didn't have time to
mention it today but there was like
quite a few interesting anecdotes like
some students felt like using this
shared network
to help their studying was cheating like
that they would use these materials
instead of textbook materials
uh somehow like gave them a better score
on their on their test
like wasn't an authentic way of learning
um
and there were other there were other um
little anecdotes about from the english
class about
uh students feeling like their ideas
were getting less like
individual creative people were getting
reduced to the kind of
mean uh creativity of the classroom um
which was a kind of unexpected point
that i thought was interesting
but yeah the documentary was really
fascinating and i'd be happy to send it
great thanks um well um
let's give will a round of applause